so let's go slide show ok so I'm I'm
kind of I kind of became the caller
expert at Wolfram so when when I noticed
that we had like this extra talk
allotted two-hour our image processing
team I decided to fill it with a caller
processing and and how you can do I mean
how you can work and what you can do
with colors in Mathematica so i'll try
to be extremely brief in the
introductory part but i think it's still
worth it to mention where in what color
are why should you care and the
internals a bit the internals about like
or representation in Mathematica so I
get that I guess as many many of you
knows about this like everybody coming
from from physics will know what the
black body is and 44 who is not from the
head and that doesn't have a physics
background basically every object at a
given temperature will emit light or
let's say electromagnetic radiation the
point is we don't see the whole
electromagnetic spectrum so we usually
just notice stuff that emits light
between a certain interval of
temperatures like here this scale here
is in Kelvin so for example the Sun is
like 3,000 Kelvin and this way we see
sunlight and we don't see like everybody
shining but if you use an infrared
camera you will you will see everybody
shining actually and so let's say so we
have an interval of temperature where
like stuff will emit light and we also
have an interval of in our like own
detector our eyes are a light detector a
little magnetic radiation detector but
they do not work at it every frequency
or wavelength so this is to be probably
and besides being too big is the what
part of the electromagnetic spectrum we
can see so these basically are the
colors that can be analyzed by your your
visual system so how how do you get
colors so let's move like to something a
bit more concrete so in the eyes we have
three kinds of cells
and and they're sensible actually
different set of wavelengths and and
these here are the sensitivities of all
the cells so you see that like they
degrade really quickly one once you are
out of the comfort zone between 4 409 o
meters and like the 700 nanometers so
given that we have like three kind of
independent photoreceptor it was kind of
obvious to represent colors with three
coordinates and in this is why actually
it's so convenient to represent colors
with three color code with three numbers
otherwise it would be like kind of
difficult to explain so a lot of people
perform experiment basically by asking
asking people to tune like knobs was
really like this was done in the 30s I
think 1931 I mean that the bubble was to
create the sensitivity to mean the
response of a human are two different
frequency and so to map to map as a
given color to a combination of r g and
b and this is what you get so basically
once you do you take those the only
thing you can do is you have to do is
just to take those function convert them
with a spectrum of whatever thing is
like whatever color it is and you will
get three numbers and those three
numbers are r g and b so this is this is
what r g and b are basically and and
those three numbers as they are like
three dimensional quantity they can be
easily visualized in a three-dimensional
space so like if you visualize RGB dean
rjb it's just the cube so this is RGB
this is not the most convenient way I
mean one of the original reason that
prompted to change this representation
is that negative numbers were not so
good and native prone to error when you
did when you had to do all the
calculations by hand so another space
was introduced like this XYZ space which
is basically just a linear combination
while gb and is defined X positively to
positively defined and has like certain
better properties for example this y
coordinate in the middle is really close
to the human sensitivity to go to the
brightness so it's like kind of a kind
of the brightness measure so if we if we
look
at the RGB space in this XYZ space we
see that is a linear combination so it's
still like rectangular eggs and doesn't
have like curve shaped but it's not a
cube anymore and and we already see
what's the advantage of having other
spaces in color representation so here
for example I mean if we go back we we
don't have a lightness axis here so like
basically if I go if I look at fully
saturated colors like red yellow green
they all the same but actually like a
color like blue is perceive much darker
than when yellow for example and this I
can already notice in this XYZ space
because I kyalo is up is that here close
to white why blue is down here close to
black and once I had this place from
this is kind of like a hub from this
place I can define all sort of other
spaces like what one example material
may have seen if it work with color is a
chromaticity diagram which is just
basically you you divide X Y Z by the
sum of x y&z so because you kind of
normalize the coordinates and then you
just pick two of them and you and you so
you define this two-dimensional space
when you can then this kind of
chromaticity diagram and these three
points here are the three coordinates
for r g and b so like 1000 10 and 0 0 1
seen in this other space so basically if
you had this RGB space ok what's a big
color part the big color part is what we
can see as human beings so these are
like the single frequency colors and
these are all the mixture of frequency
that we can see and ready we notice but
not every color that we can see is
representable by RGB so if you have free
source of light you see if resources of
life you cannot represent every color
you need take multiple sources but this
is getting efficient so is way better
just to use three and use like this
three sensitivity and so this is like
this is like kind of what's represented
and this is also the reason why
different monitors with different
primaries they are called the
coordinates of our G and B represents
colors differently so don't don't trust
your monitor when you have to send stuff
around and especially when you have to
print it because I pigments are a
different kind of primaries here in
totally different position and so
that's eight why why should I care I
mean why should you care I mean I care
because my job euchre because sometimes
things are relevant let's look at this
stupid example here I have two images
and I one image composed by two images
green and red let's do a stupid thing
like mean filter or could be a Gaussian
blur whatever so this is expected
unexpected Illinois at first I never
thought about this problem but actually
why is so dark here I mean this is green
this is red they're kind of bright here
is going down why because RGB is not
linear space when XYZ is so if you know
about this this is what one reason for
example you should care about it so if
we perform just a stupid color
conversion to XYZ e which is a linear
space it doesn't like encode colors in a
square like kind of square roots of
compression because this is another
topic I don't want to go too technical
but RGB encode scholar in nonlinear
matter so if i do the same thing in XYZ
oh this is not dark anymore this is like
nice linear mixture of color and and
this may be important something that is
overlooked by many software if you your
Mac like you have you change either
wouldn't switch folder now buddy if you
if you are like foreground and
background the background is blurred if
you blur colors in Photoshop sometimes
and you don't know about this you may
just get worse results this is just
because you're doing stuff in the wrong
space so that the core representation is
really is really important in another
stupid example like let's import an
image so this is an image of something
as we know what it is and so let's say
that this image is to contrast it I want
to reduce the contrast so we can reduce
contrast in RGB actually let's just do
this ok I've reduced the contrast but I
don't know is it really the proper thing
to do I mean this is now is really dull
is the sort of gray in the image but if
I know about Carlos places I'm a convert
to another color space and then we
talked about this a little bit more
about this later for example this l CH
space is a likeness chroma and Hugh so
as I have a chrome / saturation
single like the Tosh parameter is like
it auto cannot do the others I can just
reduce that and I get totally different
result and these things that these are
just little things but of course you can
you can build much more on top of this
if you if you know when like what are
the properties of your spaces so oh this
is okay this is too much too long let's
say let's move briefly about how do we
represent colors in the Wolfram language
I mean we have basically three like they
say two ways of representing color and
three concept and one is color directive
that you you may be for me with that
it's like when you type like RGB color
and then you do like 100 with this is
red for example or you can say la be
color more nelly be later and like
something like this this is another
color and so these are color directly so
you can use them you can you can extract
the numbers multiplied about the things
you can place I mean images I mean you
can do all sort of things and this like
the proper color representation and of
course like this canvas tip in
manipulate that shows i could happens
when you change the primaries but i mean
i think everybody is familiar with this
then we have color in images so let's
get our faithful leaner so okay this
thing is not gonna work in the
presentation mode but if now i go to the
normal working mode i had this image
information panel and i see that for
example see lot of things about this is
the image histograms and I i see that
colors are encoded in a bite format so
from 0 to 255 that they are interleaved
and end this space is RGB and I can even
without calling caller convert I can
change the like this thing will
automatically call color from convert
from for me if I just do for example
something like this so this is the same
image in the LA be space I mean it's the
same because leb is bigger than RGB so
I'm not cutting anything but if i
convert for example to grayscale allow
throwing away information so i can don't
do this if you want to go back just save
the image
and so I mean I can get the options so
like this is what happens when I convert
and I can get the data out this is not
probably so interesting but it's really
used for the good image data out if you
want to do operations on the single
single xls number so let's go back to
the presentation here let's say we have
like space is not really an object in
the world from language but it's a
concept is really useful so like we
talked about RGB those those functions
but that I show before well like the
official definition of RGB by by the the
color consortium international
consortium but actually that space is
kind of big so as you don't want to wait
when you map from one let me having
different primaries means you can
present different colors so you don't
want to to represent too many colors if
you if you need your images to be
compatible with many devices so the
industry standard is not that big space
like something that I don't be Microsoft
came together to define and is this srgb
which is way smaller and you see it here
and this is what we use internally
Mathematica so if you wonder what is our
definition of RGB is srgb and and if you
look at srgb in in different independent
spaces you see you see basically his
property this is we saw already XYZ we
talked before about a la BLC else eh
what's that basically oh well this is
the 3d representation then then we saw
like from the chromaticity diagram that
was too d visas in 3d so if i look from
above I see the triangle and if I look
from the side is just this is just the
projection basically on an axis of this
one here so I justify normalizing I get
this this wise questo pin' at the bottom
and this is now a space mrs. this is
like a mean let's say an innovation over
like an an update / of X X Y Z is called
la be I don't go into the details but
has no lot of nonlinear transformation
and this makes the core representation
way closer to what we as human being
perceived so if I measured for example
at Euclidean distance in this place is
much closer to the perceived color
distance of myself as human and I still
have a good property that color
like properly placed on the luminance
axis or like if i go from the center
which is the line of grey color to the
side i have that chrome a measure that I
used before so is analogous to the
saturation somehow so i can perform all
kind of operation in this space and it
as the color information is more
perceptually accurate this is the reason
why i was using LA be to cluster collars
yesterday in my classifier so let's said
let's let's quickly move to the this all
double oh and then we have like more
color utilities that you probably know
about random color it's quite
sophisticated you can pass also
distribution so like this one would
think about like a usual lch so i can
specify an interval of luminance and
interval of chroma and interval of hue
and this is quite useful when you have
to create color palette and i have
function like color distance for example
like this is a rose i can create a mask
by the defining the coral distance from
image to do a single color that you can
just directly use image color of this
will automatically tried over all the
pixels and then i can do something like
selective desaturation which is a really
popular let's say image effect
application just by combining the two
this is something that's really easy to
do like three lines of code in
Mathematica and so you don't have to
download your iPhone app or maybe you
have whatever and okay and this is like
was kind of brief introduction what was
our color and what we can do with them
in poor form language let's go quickly
super quickly to some application of
this so the image adjusting first first
function but okay this spot here is kind
of sneak peek into 10.2 because all
these functions here are at it will be
available in 10.2 so white balance
what's white balance is strictly like
closely related to color processing is
like I kind of let's say I I didn't
mention one step before like when I talk
about like how do you get RGB colors
convolving the spectrum with those free
functions is but usually any like given
object here
doesn't emit light so it's not really
emitted light is reflected light so
there's a one step in the middle you you
have like the spectrum of view of your
wire like light source like the Sun or
one they say watt light bulb or
fluorescent lamp whatever so that is the
spectrum you have to convert that with
the reflectance bedroom of the object
and then with the functions and I mean
given that certain colors the RGB colors
that you get in the end are really
dependent on which kind of light source
you use and that's kind of obvious
because if you think about it if you are
shining something with a red light it
will look right in the end and you
cannot see any other color and this is a
problem white balancing mean what
happens if you have like a different
source of light which is not direct
sunlight the content of image will be
different and it just I I browse through
the internet before and I gather a bunch
of exam or test images from paper some
address common images from google images
and but what we have in common is that
they are not really well white balanced
I mean they are not they have not been
corrected for improper illumination so
with the white balance function I mean
just shown here like you have like a lot
of biscuits to correct images from the
stupid one like this is one here is this
should be way way smaller let's try this
still too big or lady
but okay so some some of them are like
four it's stupid for exam of this gray
scaling is use a really popular
assumption which is a gray ward that's
so let's say that the average content of
a natural image it has to be gray but
it's not really powerful so like for
example the first images can fix it the
second one yes this bowl yes but for
many others like scaling stuff in RGB is
not really the proper way to go because
you can quickly hit the boundary of that
cube and then you have all this clipping
so you can do I mean this is really fast
but doesn't work all the time now you
can use another assumption which is like
not the average color is gray but it's
like at least one object is white in
real-world image it's sometimes a
justify sometimes it's not still I can
fix certain images but for example this
really strong green and blue color cast
they cannot be fixed because there's no
basically if there's just one white
pixel or like the older the maximum
pixel images are white I cannot fix it I
can do this scaling not in RGB button in
otherspace this LMS scaling is just the
three function we saw before it's kind
of I move in there in an obvious way
switched kind of a response domain of
our cone cells and I do the scaling here
and I think i can get much better result
for many images but still I cannot
correct every image i see this lab here
of this woman here and then the final
finally the most powerful we have here
is scaling the chromaticity what is that
basically is the kind of a great word
assumption but I don't just multiply
colors I just take out the chromaticity
so not the brightness information just
the color like the hue information from
the image and i scaled that and this
it's really powerful can fix many things
but it requires multiple conversion so
it's generally slower so other new
utilities we have like I don't know if
you're familiar with HDR images like you
can you can create HDR is like high
dynamic range images that means that I
have a lot of exposure information
different level of brightness all
compacted in one image the problem is
that usually no that's not import from
internet usually what i get is something
like this so it's really dark
but if you multiply by something you see
that the color information is there but
like just straight multiplication is
never good because I'm burning out all
the light RFA's I mean this is over
overexposed so what what you want to do
is to turn up the image and so you just
kind of mix locally the brightness
information from all the areas and if
you don't like it this is all them all
so many methods we do and you could go
in details but you can make it more
powerful less powerful there are here a
lot of methods they can just scale the
RGB primaries you can scale the
luminance of the picture the logarithm
illuminance and you have like some more
advanced methods like divide the
luminance in details and they scale the
bass put back the details or just
simulate the analog dodging and burning
and and of course you can correct for
like with the parameters like this log
luminous for example was quite dark you
cannot fix like automatic parameters for
every image so I prefer to let be the
user fixed on themselves beyond a
certain level let's say so you can make
it more powerful but let's say now is a
bit too de saturated so I would manually
fix the saturation for example and you
can do all sort of things with this
another another really interesting color
process application is correlated to to
HDR images but not strictly the same
thing is like image talking in this
specific case exposure stacking so let's
say I have a problem that i want to see
these details of luminosity or
brightness level but i don't have like
super sensible sense so like it is
different levels i have just normal
camera so what i can do i can take
multiple pictures a different level of
exposure or different at a time a
different opportunities and this i
should have saved is it connected yes so
like these pictures have different level
of exposure and what I can do with
mathematica 10.2 is just call one
function and combine them in one this is
quite big so it takes some time and here
it is so basically this is is applying
lot of local filters to get the proper
exposure for each image and combining
them all
and another thing that you can do with
this like by combining exposure is let's
not go to internet let's take images
from here because we don't have much
time so yes you can so you can like take
your not your average but like a good
underexposed image if you have a good
sensor but will still say it is an
unresponsive edge is really dark but has
a lot of information in the dark channel
oh it's really fast it's coming Oh No
who knows mm-hmm either ok I will tell
you the trick and then this you can see
for yourself if you download the
notebook so basically what you can do is
a simulate multiple exposure by an oh
here it is so here's the image which is
really dark but if i multiply this by
like different different levels again I
can I can see that here is not so I mean
it will burn out faster because it's not
HDR this is not low dynamic range but
still I can simulate multiple exposure
sometimes if the image is not too bad
and then combine it to let me I starting
from this and now I have this so it's
kind of looked kind of fake this is why
a lot of high dynamic range like kind of
high dynamic range images on the web
look this way because we are not really
high dynamic range we are like over
comprise to stuff like that but still
you can extract details but you cannot
see and with the naked eye let's say on
the picture another like kind of not
really color processing but is related
to image stacking is focus stacking so
no no that's not important let's from my
hard drive so this is a fly that i got
from Wikipedia you can get basically
this is instead of different exposure
you have different focal lengths so this
part here has the from text in focus
besides the back and i can just call
again image focus come by to confine
them combine them this is a bit ugly why
because images are not aligned so please
remember to align your images and once
you do that you get this and you can
this like macro photography another
popular application of this is
microscopy so let's import this stock of
cell images so this is again three
different focus planes and what they can
visit is a regular
nine so I don't need I don't need to
align it myself but I can chill a bit a
little option here so I can align really
quickly or I can create multiple maps at
multiple a resolution level and and take
longer of course but let's see the
result so this is first image second
third this is a fast combination and
this is a proper combination with more
time and just to comparison this is a
image i took from Wikipedia as a ground
truth so and then did I think I even
have less ghosting here at least we get
even better for like ten point 1 1021 or
whatever is fairly new and experimental
so that's said I had some example here
but i don't know if i have time to show
them how much time do i have just five
minutes do you want to see more examples
oh no ok oh good so this one here is
yeah so these are more like kind of fun
applications so what what you can do
with the colors we have a colorized
function so like for example this is a
pattern and and if if you do something
like let's say let's do a segmentation
so this will create a mattress metrics
of numbers and I would be like 123 each
component will be labeled with a
correspondent number and then you how do
you visualize the metrics of integer
components usually you call color eyes
and you get this this is kind of random
colors that we picked it to be like far
apart but not necessarily beautiful so
what you can do is take like for example
inspiration from nature like this is a
picture of the quince you can call
random colors and create your own rules
so you have something like this because
usually usually is good to take color
from real things because nature tend to
be our monic or maybe we tend to proceed
that as ironic because it's all around
us whatever so you can do these kind of
things and I have many example here but
I'm not going through all of them
because you don't have time and other
things you can do is for example let's
take this marine moral image this one is
stole from Marcus thanks Marcus and what
you can do is take out coloring
mission and then again use the real word
image let me again I will do
segmentation and I use the real world
image to get some color rules and then
up my homemade Pop Art em and then here
I directly i'm still in Marcus this is
marcus running so thanks again Marcus
what is this OOP sorry this is a video
of Marcus after his run his morning run
and what we want to do here is to use
the color information on his face to
measure his pulse after the run and how
do we do that I mean first we have like
a bunch of regularization we extract his
face we measure extras with skin I don't
to show all this means all in the
notebook but for example let's say these
are all the face sees we saw a
regularized faces mmm skin classifiers
skin wait okay specialist for example so
this is like by taking with a manual
mask I select layer selected them skin
pixel in the picture and then by taking
the average of that overall the images
of a line faces that you can align
yourself let's go before you can get the
average that like let's say skin mask of
Marcos face so when I had this I can
just extract the LAV signal so from them
so the color information from the the
pixel of the face we don't really care
about the likeness here this is why we
go to a la be because so we can use a
and B so we have two colors let's try to
come to colors channel let's try to
combine them in the most like an
information-rich way so we find the
optimal mixing angle and now we get
something which looks a bit more with
just a linear combination for a mb this
looks a lot more now like a pulse still
we want to clean the signal a little so
we use a bandpass filter in order to get
the proper frequency into account we
find the peak of all those frequencies
so now we have basically two different
oscillations
one my guess is the breath so while your
briefing a your your skin color would
change one is a post is much faster it's
like every time there's more blood in
your face you will get rather and so
let's try to get the the time difference
between all these peaks so we extract
the time difference we convert the delta
T two seconds we'll get some standard
deviation and then what we can do is we
can just measure the pulse so this is 82
feet per minute it was the post of
Marcus after his run and the run is done
I'm done because end is out there thanks
you for your attention